Speaker 1: One other Trump interview I want
to look at before we move on from yesterday,
and this is really interesting.
Trump was interviewed by Rob Schmitt on Newsmax.
Rob Schmitt is one of the people that went
after me about a month and a half ago when
I pointed out prayer doesn't prevent mass
shootings, Rob Schmitt jumped on the bandwagon.
This is just fascinating.
Trump claims during this interview that he
got rid of Roe v Wade.
This this is very interesting, inconsequential.
Listen to.
Speaker 2: This.
Your response to his allegation on this.
And I want to ask also, do you think that
six weeks is going too far?
Is that going to doom Republicans with the
moderates in.
Speaker 3: This country when it comes to 2024?
Rob, first of all, I'm the one that got rid
of Roe v Wade and everybody said that was
an impossible thing to do.
I put on three Supreme Court justices.
Very few people have had the privilege or
honor, and they are terrific people.
And they happen to believe that Roe v Wade
should not be there.
It's been now brought back to the states.
And what I've done is I've given the pro-life
people who are wonderful people and loving
people.
I've given them the power of negotiation,
because now they're able to negotiate something
that's going to be very important.
Speaker 1: So Trump saying he really got rid
of Roe v Wade by virtue of having appointed
the Supreme Court justices he appointed, I
would agree.
I actually Trump shockingly not lying, at
least metaphorically, about that.
The midterm voters noticed and they voted
the way they did, in part because of that.
This should be a Democratic campaign ad paid
for by Joe Biden.
Right.
I'm Joe Biden and I approve this message.
Trump saying I'm the one that got rid of Roe
v Wade.
If indeed Trump is the Republican nominee.
Then Trump went back to the lies, including
laughably claiming that the Durham report
is the biggest story in the history of the
United States.
Speaker 3: This is the biggest story of maybe
in the history of our country.
It's grim at the century.
Look at what they report on on other people.
I won't mention names.
Other people were there.
They're caught cold, they're criminals, and
they don't even report.
They refuse.
You know, you can't have a scandal if you
don't have publicity, To be honest.
You cannot have a scandal.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, I already told
you about the truth of the Durham report.
It is not exposing the crime of the century.
In fact, the report even says we're not aware
of any crimes at all committed by anyone in
the investigation of Donald Trump through
the Mueller investigation that's in the Mueller
report, that's in the Durham report, rather.
And Trump continues to lie and lie and lie.
And by the way, we still haven't figured out
what Obama gate is.
Trump told us Obama gate biggest political
crime of the century.
I don't know which century, and we still don't
even know what Obama gate is.
And then lastly, Trump lamenting that they
want to fire the head of CNN after that big
beautiful town hall that Trump did.
Speaker 3: Or doing before what they do seven,
eight, nine months.
To a birth of a child, the life of a child.
Those are the radical people, not the pro-life
people.
Those are the radical people.
And I think I explained it very well the other
night on on CNN.
You know so well that they want to fire the
head of CNN and they want to fire let he got
the highest ratings that they had in many
years.
And they want to go out and they want to fire.
So, you know, you explain that when the whole
world is topsy turvy and what I say about
words.
Speaker 1: It's a topsy turvy world out there.
Now, the truth is CNN's ratings for the Trump
town hall weren't actually that great.
It was about 3 million, which actually is
quite good for CNN in the sense that CNN ratings
are in the toilet.
And actually this is insane.
But Newsmax had higher viewership than CNN
during some primetime hour late last week
or earlier this week, which is genuinely stunning
stuff.
I mean, it shows you the lack of interest
in what CNN is offering.
It's not really true, though, that the CNN
town hall ratings were that great.
What happened was Trump's behavior on the
town hall was so outrageous that after the
fact.
The reality of CNN doing the town hall is
what made news.
And the disaster of Kaitlan Collins is attempts
to kind of hold Trump accountable.
And the lie is second that Trump told.
That's what got attention.
Trump likes to think, oh, CNN Live got a huge
ratings boost because of me.
The truth is, Trump's behavior was so deplorable
during the town hall that after the fact,
anybody who pays attention to what's going
on in the 2024 race certainly commented on
it.
So the lies just spewing out of Trump's mouth.
But he's clearly doing something that's impressing
the Republican primary voters because he keeps
building his lead over DeSantis in the primary
polls, as we talked about at the top of the
show.
Let's take a quick break.
All of these clips I played are going to be
on our Instagram, on our YouTube channel,
on our TikTok.
Check them out there.
And we'll be right back.